yoru used to be the worst valorent agent
so much so that riot decided to give him
a major overhaul revising most of his
abilities and if you didn't notice
everyone is interlocking him making
crazy plays with his hyper aggro
abilities he's definitely more fun but
the most important question is has yoru
been saved
all right y'all before i get into the
video i have to remind you as always the
like button the subscribe button and to
ring the notification bell if you don't
i'm so sorry
but all these changes are going away mr
ryan told me himself riot did it y'all
let's give it up for riot
they gave our japanese agent the buff he
not only deserved but needed remember a
little while ago when i asked the
question can yuru be saved it was with
the news that a rework was coming and i
honestly didn't really know what to
expect we knew a little bit about the
changes but nothing was super concrete
and then 4.04 dropped i learned that i
should never have cheated on killjoy
with astra since i nerfed her into the
ground with this patch along with viper
but besides the controller balances the
euro rework arrived and then all of
y'all decided to insta-lock yoru that
night and ruin my games but
i digress the first revision we have is
his fake out we now only have one charge
but it sends a whole ass decoy forward
if it's shot by the enemy this happens
one enemy remaining
oh this decoy slash clone has 150 hp and
if you shoot it it'll turn and stare at
you and then flash you it is beyond
terrifying anyways my love for bad boys
aside this decoy allows for some pretty
sneaky plays with people pretending to
be the decoy and by pretty sneaky i mean
y'all are doing absolutely insane plays
that i cannot escape from on my timeline
yes yes yes or some not so sneaky plays
moving on his tp now has two charges
which resets on two kills like a raised
grenade which makes tens a very happy
duelist
thank you that's exciting
top
oh my god this character is insane what
the
two tps that refresh after you get two
kills
this is honestly a big deal because yoru
was always supposed to be the agent that
rewarded deception plus aggression
having these two tps with the kill reset
means people are going to get very
creative with pushes and retakes and
they are going to be rewarded for that
the tp also now travels faster and has a
smaller sound radius which honestly was
one of my biggest issues with it your
wasn't really sneaky when you just heard
this wow wow wow goodbye and you have
the option to fake it all in all a huge
rework for one ability that honestly
really needed it before these changes it
was honestly one of the weakest
signature abilities in the game it was
loud and it was easy to sniff out a fake
so these changes will be huge for him in
the words of riot themselves while the
goal of the fake teleport is to create
confusion about yoru's location you
should be able to go where the fake
teleport occurred and then understand
whether the real yoru is around or was
it a misdirection oh so spooky and as
someone who always falls for the hey
there's gullible written on the ceiling
you can imagine how i feel about these
changes
hey shut up danny i hate them i fall for
them every time i'm easily misdirected
by things
well at least i'm cute
moving on to his blinds yoru's blinds
were kind of the clunkiest and they
still are nothing changed but his alt
did and honestly this is probably one of
my favorite changes as yuru you can now
use utility while in your ult which also
lasts two seconds longer as the unlucky
enemy in addition to being on the
receiving end of this utility you can no
longer see where he is though you can
hear his footsteps this is awesome
because yoru's ult was really most
successful at info grabbing sometimes
you'd get a nice ult plus shoddy combo
but it was really mostly for running
around the site and pinging where you
saw people having nuru have the ability
to cast his utility specifically his
blind is great for the rest of the team
he can lead the pack safely while others
push him behind him and his util this
ult change in my opinion was the most
needed his old needed a major makeover
in order to be a true ultimate i think
this really does that so where are we
when it comes to saving yoru well here
were my thoughts a little while ago
about my hopes for the changes
the concept of yoru is great ballarat
needs a stealth agent which is why they
created him hopefully these changes can
bring him more in line with their
original vision of him so they made
these changes in line with their stealth
idea and honestly i think they half hit
on it we can clearly tell he is more
stealthy but honestly not as stealthy as
i was looking forward to and honestly i
think i was a little foolish to think
yoru would be super sneaky with this kit
it makes it really hard for you to be
the silent stealth agent i believed he
was supposed to be the blinds the
teepees and the decoys none of them are
truly sneaky in the traditional sense
they are very loud and very blunt where
i think riot really did succeed is in
making him tricky he is tricky now the
fake teepee the blinds the decoy the ult
yuru is a fantastic agent albeit a very
niche one he's kind of like the jester
of the valerant protocol not very subtle
all the time but very good in this
direction and in a game like valorent
which is heavily reliant on accurate
intel yoru really stands out as a pick
for someone who really wants to set
their team up for a success at the
professional competitive level i think
there's a really awesome opportunity to
shake up the professional meta as
valerian continues its second
competitive year team comps have become
predictable and that's okay things
stabilize well most things maybe right
now isn't the best time to try things
out but who knows here's what tens
thinks about the changes i think it's
good i mean i still think he's a
situational character i don't really
think there's ever going to be a time
where he's like amazing amazing but who
knows uh we'll really see
so what do you think are the yoru maine
satisfied or any doulas thinking of
switching what do you think of the
rework all i know is yuru and his
changes have made the game really
exciting you guys have found a new
energy in game and i am living for it
i was getting ready to shoot right and
i'm like moving my chair and then all of
a sudden this pops out for my chair
i don't know
it's a giant
screw and i don't know where it came
from
what did i do
right in the middle of like danny
livestream no
danny that's not funny